prise de température gel hydroalcoolique
et masque obligatoire
les indiens appelés aux urnes pour des
élections législatives déjà controversé
et dernière semaine marquée par des
rassemblements de dizaines de milliers
de personnes souvent son mas
[Applaudissements]
le seuil des cent mille nouveaux cas
dépasser en 24 heures un record
place donc à un couvre feu nocturne de
22h à 5h du matin jusqu'à fin avril à
new delhi 25 millions de personnes sont
concernées dans la capitale indienne
le couvre feu nocturne n'a pas vraiment
de sens parce que la nuit la plupart des
magasins et des endroits sont fermés je
ne pense vraiment pas qu'il soit
efficace
je pense qu'un couvre feu deux jours
seraient efficaces comme l'année
dernière pas de confinement nationale
mais l'état de maharashtra et sa
capitale bombe est désormais sous cloche
le week end
en semaine le couvre-feu a même été
avancé de 20 heures à 19 heures des
regroupements de population à éviter
souhait du gouvernement pakistanais et
des autorités de la province de sind au
sud est du pays les écoles primaires et
collèges vont temporairement fermés tout
comme les salles de mariage un réel
problème
des milliers d'ouvriers travaillent dans
les salles de banquets ici à karachi le
gouvernement imposer ces nouvelles
restrictions est maintenant beaucoup de
gens se retrouvent sans emploi alors que
le ramadan et l'aïd approche
comment allons nous faire pour nourrir
nos enfants on ne sait pas quoi faire
lueur d'espoir venu tout de même de
russie levac sens pout nick v fait des
émules à karachi depuis le week-end
dernier un vaccin de doses à la vente au
sein d'établissements privés les jeunes
pakistanais n'est pas encore désignés
prioritaires à la vaccination se sont
donc rués dans les cliniques tout
sourire
le masque en revanche du côté du
bangladesh le pays a débuté cette
semaine un confinement de sept jours
pour combattre une flambée du virus avec
tous les déplacements intérieurs
suspendu et une fermeture des magasins
une situation intenable pour certains
nous ne pourrons pas prendre en charge
notre famille si le confinement se
prolonge
comment allons-nous pouvoir gérer cela
ça me rend fou que devons nous faire
l lundi lors d'une manifestation anti
restrictions un étudiant de 20 ans a été
tué et au moins sept personnes ont été
blessées dont trois policiers dans la
ville centrale de salta